because alex copp makes his eighth start
of the year it's three wins it's two
losses it's a three point seven eight
eight fastball movement gets some ground
balls with that 57 percent there it is
ground ball action
that's exactly what it is strike
throwing son of a gun is alex cobb and
you better be ready because it's active
and it's moving
there's another split-fingered fastball
there's that man again anthony rendon
[Applause]
218 career homers that's not going to be
one of those it's a three ground ball
out inning
exactly the way cobb likes it
you say kakuchi
getting the start really pitched well in
his last outing overall this will be his
11th starting on the season three and
three record at 388 era
62 and two thirds how about 61
strikeouts over 20 watts
oh good pitch
strike three on upton one down
and now a
match-up of a couple of guys who know
each other from their days playing in
japan shohei three for seven in his
career against him with a home run
and it's not their first match-up shell
gets to know his friend again with the
home run
shohei ohtani
yard
16th of the season second versus kikuchi
jumping on the first pitch and doing the
damage
in his
previous nine years swinging a miss got
him
two down
one in a runner on brings up max stassi
the catcher
everest come in with a record of 29 and
30 the angels at 26 and 31 good looking
breaking ball that'll do it ohtani hit a
long long home run angels have a
one-nothing lead
so here is jake fraley
didn't mean to rolls that one to the
right side iglesias with the glove
in time
welcome back he was a man on a mission
2-2 here to walsh
breaking ball a good one good pitch
that's three consecutive strikeouts it's
four
vulgate
okay chase that one big strikeout number
five already as we play here in the
second inning two down
2-2 pitch
there's tremel
[Applause]
and the lagaris one out double does no
harm one-nothing angels
pulls that one
as david charging in
turns kelnick into an out
every single out on the ground
hitler's in five of bats in this series
three strikeouts
splitter
[Applause]
the first strikeout of the game for cobb
here's the one-two swing and a mess he
got him
ebola disappeared low in the zone upton
swings through strikeout number six for
kikuchi that brings up shohei ohtani
went deep last time
two two
here's the breaking ball yep
that's in its excellent location on it
he has a tough time left on left with
that breaking ball running away from him
and the mariners have their first base
runner
lead off walk in the fourth
2-2
pitch sinking liner to base hit
taylor ward will get it back in and here
come the mariners a walk in a base that
first hit of the ball game
and now the bases are loaded is
ty france gets hit by a pitch again
here's taylor tremell baroness as a team
fourth in the big leagues runners in
scoring position chopper off the bench
oh there's a break we got a tie ball
game there is a break freely can put it
and play hard somewhere get a lead
that's hit really well carrying back to
the track up against the wall it's gone
a great slam for jake friendly and the
mariners have a 5-1 lead
second home run of the series second
home run of his big league career
two momentous occasions for jake fraley
max dassey nine of 36 this year
high fly ball kellnick tracking to the
warning track to the wall win baby win
when stassi does that homer for max well
that baseball is kept carrying second
home run that's his power swing david
fletcher the hitter flight out to the
left yakuchi's got him all two
oh off his leg
good joy oh and he threw it away
and coming around to score
is ward
you say still on the ground
goodness gracious oh
wait oh and then the fall right there i
think that might have been that might
have been it looked like he twisted his
knee going down to the ground brendon
singled to left field
anthony right back through the middle
off the glove of walton
here comes flex to score big chance big
hit anthony rendon
you know when it's early april late
march and take those chips and just push
it in we're with him
inside corner
that's another zero on the scoreboard
that's eight in a row sat down since the
grand slam and his team's coming back
the batter now is taylor ward
that one well struck toward that wall
and left center field ward did it
mom and dad looking on taylor with a
blast and the angels all the way back
lead at 6'5 fifth home run of the year
for taylor ward
[Applause]
on the ground you'll take it
good spot
ground ball out the ground ball machine
to get the ground ball out
looks like he's going back to it again
outside corner that strike three
[Applause]
what a gutsy outing you know these are
the games you really relish as a pitcher
you give up five but you get a chance to
get back and give the team an
opportunity to win and you can pick up a
w also infield in here now
on the ground
that is an rbi that's great base running
on contact
up and scored easily on that ball
swing and a miss
down goes seeger
a little roller right side big shift was
on oh my goodness
that is an incredible play
runners at second and third nobody out
and the next spatter will be lagaris
fights that off there are those two
rbi's for lagarus
out on runs for the angels oh how good
does that feel juan and the angels add
on and now lead it nine to five
jay up
that one is down it will roll all the
way toward that wall
one angel scoring here comes fletch to
score
and justin upton gets it done boy has he
really come through nay's last two at
bats
fights off a breaking ball
down and left oh he's flying takes the
turn heading to second shohei with the
double
breaking ball that'll do it what a come
from behind victory for the halos